le dernier bastion du sexisme est tombé
marguerite yourcenar élue à l'académie
française
teheran espoir pour les otages
américains
les étudiants les ont remis au conseil
de la révolution le scandale du
transport des chevaux la colère de
brigitte bardot mais à messieurs bonsoir
l'académie française n'avait pas vu cela
depuis trois cent quarante cinq ans
depuis sa création une femme en effet
chez les immortels marguerite yourcenar
a en effet tout à l'heure été élu au
fauteuil de roger caillois par 20 voix
contre 12 à jean dorst de directeur du
musée d'histoire naturelle 20 voix c'est
de dire une voix de plus seulement que
la majorité requise n'est pas sûr que
marguerite yourcenar lesage déjà est en
effet actuellement en voyage en amérique
centrale et dans les caraïbes martin
laroche joubert a vécu sous la coupole
ce moment historique ont obtenu madame
yourcenar 20 voix monsieur dorst 12 voix
bulletins blancs marqués d'une croix 3
et bulletins blancs 1
par conséquent madame yourcenar
succédera à roger caillois
moi j'appartenais à l'opposition oui
pourquoi
je peux me dit non non non parce que de
là l'idée que
l'académie pendant 300 ans n'est ce pas
des puissants semble qu'elle pouvait
encore vivre trois séances
d'entraînement
vous avez voté pour ou contre marguerite
yourcenar nathalie envers de pas à vous
ne voulez pas dire non parce qu'un ami
et live meeting et mervin pour qg bonpé
de malet et 2
agent n'est pas un anti féministe alors
pas du tout non pas du tout j'ai une vie
chatel frédéric hébrard qui a fait 2
oui certainement la chose un niveau qui
a attiré un millier en mon jeu est là et
je donnerai bien
bon là vous êtes pour l'ancrer d'autre
part encore à gagner car on veut quand
même en va pas reconnaître parentaux
siens femmes et les 21000 deux hommes
serait ridicule
la règle est que à l'académie française
celui où max ans celle qui est élu et
les nus de tous
et pourquoi avez-vous pensé à ma
collection c'est parce que je pense que
marc hecker sonar est un des plus grands
écrivains vivants et je pense que c'est
un honneur pour moi réduire sonars des
dalakhani française est à l'honneur pour
la qualif française d'avoir parmi elles
marc hecker cela se joue ce qu'il y
avait une autre élection au fauteuil
cette fois de joseph kessel c'est michel
droit qui l'a emporté par 19 voix contre
13 au recteur mallet michel roy qui
partage ses ce fut passion entre la
presse écrite la télévision il fut à ce
bureau il ya une vingtaine d'années et
puis le roman roman s'ouvre historique
michel droit est en effet très attachés
au souvenir du général de gaulle mais
parlons surtout de marguerite yourcenar
dont l'élection fait sensation parce que
c'est une femme bien sûr mais aussi
parce qu'elle possède à la fois la
nationalité française et américaine
comme julien green et surtout parce que
c'est un très bon écrivain qui va on
vous l'a dit honoré l'académie bernard
pivot l'avait l'année dernière rencontre
est dans son île américaine c'est là que
vous dites quelque part je seek ou que
vous connaissez mieux
adrien que votre père sûrement parce que
tout de même nous avons pas mal de
document assure adrien il est vrai
qu'ils sont fragmentaires et il est vrai
que beaucoup émane de chroniqueurs mais
york qui ne comprenaient pas au vaincu
qui s'exhale gérait les choses qui les
voyaient d'une façon et rudimentaire et
naïve comme des journalistes pas très
informé mais en fait nous mêmes les
documents ment pas sur mon père j'ai un
certain nombre de documents jettent pas
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs
j'ai eu aussi des périodes dhombres
tandis que la période les périodes dont
pour pour moi sont très importantes
il ya pour adrien une période de
pénombre
lorsqu'il met jeunes officiers lorsqu'il
fait la guerre parce qu'il accepte une
possible bien obligé de faire la
politique de son prédécesseur mais nous
savons pas grand chose s'était porté lui
même en quelque sorte la presque oublié
une fois arrivé au pouvoir
mais c'est tout même intérieur dans
lequel nous ne voyons pas dans des
tailles c'est quand même curieux vous
puissiez dire que vous connaissez mieux
un empereur du deuxième set après
jésus-christ que votre père avait vécu
pendant vingt deux ans et l'illusion est
un qui pense aux gens que la famille
dont on est excessivement proche
voyons un peu des choses de près un père
est un monsieur qui vous a eu comme
fidon encore teinté la vie 45 ans mais
dont je vais commencer à l'observer
quand j'en avais moi cette il en avait
donc 52 donc toute sa jeunesse était
derrière lui
j'ai dû reconstituer sa jeunesse par ces
récits qui heureusement était assez
abondant des nous les poser des
questions il y a répondu un peu plus
tard qu'à l'âge de 7 ans évidemment et
ensuite il y a le fait que le fait même
d'être une fille fausses ou à fils
foncez c'est la situation des gardiens
personnages et mon père et on pense pas
assez que ce père est un monsieur et à
sa vie à lui ses aventures à lui ses
soucis à lui et qui peut être un très
bon père mais que le fait de la
paternité ne le voit ne le compensent
pas entièrement
il ya d'autres éléments qu'on risque
d'oublier voilà nous aurons le plaisir
de voir l'intégralité de cet entretien
tout à l'heure vers 22h 22h10 alors d'un
art pivot vous aviez encontre et donc
les dernières amende d heure
c'est-à-dire au large du maine
marguerite de crayencour yourcenar est
en effet l'anagramme de marguerite de
crayencour cette femme qui a aujourd'hui
76 ans qu'elle quel genre de femme s
écouter mais je suis resté une journée
avec elle dont je peux pas vous en
parler longtemps mais ce que je peux
dire c'est que je regardais belle cette
image d'une petite femme dans une cape
grise au bord de l'atlantique et au
dessus de cette cap griz n'avait plus
beau sourire du monde
avait pas mal d'ironie dans un sourire
et puisqu'on parlait dans l'extrait
d'adrien je dirais que marie turgeon a
ressemble beaucoup à adrien cet empereur
romain qui qui gouvernait un immense
empire au deuxième siècle après
jésus-christ et si elle a écrit
magistralement ses mémoires c'est que
justement il ya beaucoup de
ressemblances entre lens et ressemblance
est le même goût pour la poésie même
goût pour les voyages le même goût pour
lui une culture cosmopolite et marie
thurso nars est aussi bien parlé avec
beaucoup de chaleur des poètes grecs des
romanciers japonais de virginia woolf du
château de chenonceau de piranèse de de
l'écologie etc
et puis enfin même goût une recherche
très constante de la sagesse une sagesse
videmment chancelante une sage est
fuyante mais qu'on gouverne qu'on écrive
la sagesse est justement de courir après
akale filiation littéraire pourriez lui
trouver aucune moi je dors je crois
qu'elle est moins pas qu'on y retrouve
une filiation elle aime pas être classé
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il ya dans
son oeuvre qui est assez abondante il ya
deux grands massifs
évidemment les mémoires d'hadrien le pro
noir qui sont deux oeuvres à la
frontière de l'histoire du roman et de
la poésie
et puis de livres de souvenirs dans
lesquels raconte la vie de ses ancêtres
m 1 et paternel c'est-à-dire souvenirs
plus est le point noir alors si on
cherche un coma délamine à tort à tous
ces ouvrages sont un peu difficiles en
trente secondes on peut dire que tout ce
qu'elle recherche dans ses livres marie
tueur sonars au fond savoir qu'elle est
là la part du masque dans notre vie est
ce que pourquoi certains hommes sont
plus libres que d'autres et puis
peut-être aussi qu'est-ce qui fait
est-ce que nous sommes maîtres de notre
destinée
je crois que ce qu'elle met toujours en
oeuvre dans ses livres marie thurso
narré avec une élégance avec un grand
steve ce sont les forces de les force
d'intelligence et force de culture les
forces de générosité je me souviens
toujours de ce mois de meerab d'adrien
c'est à dire donc de marie thurso nahmad
rien dit ceci tous les peuples ont péri
jusqu'ici parce qu'ils ont manqué de
générosité pour agression sur l'art que
nous retrouvons donc avec vous tout à
l'heure vers 22 heures
l'actualité internationale maintenant a
commencé tout d'abord parce début de
déblocage dans la sphère des otages de
l'ambassade américaine de téhéran
les étudiants islamiques ont en effet
accepté de remettre les otages au
conseil de la révolution c'est-à-dire à
une institution plus responsables dont
on peut espérer qu'elle fera accélérer
les négociations pour libérer ces
prisonniers
ça d'ailleurs pas été sans mal nous
voyons ici des iraniens manifester
contre cette décision
ailleurs la réaction américaine est
extrêmement prudente nous avons connu
dans cette affaire trop de chaud et de
froid a dit le département d'état en
attendant la commission d' enquête des
nations unies pour avoir tous les otages
le président ma nissan a même souhaité
qu'on leur demande leur témoignage à une
date qui n'a pas encore été fixée et de
tâches toujours cette fois l'ambassade
de la république dominicaine à bogota
libération ce matin de l'un des
diplomates
l'ambassadeur d'autriche dont la femme
est très malade la santé du maréchal
tito rien ne changeait le même
communiqué que la veille avec toujours
la même formule relatives aux soins
intensifs indispensable l'afghanistan
maintenant car les nouvelles qui nous
parviennent de là bas sont dramatiques
l'offensive contre les rebelles à la
frontière du pakistan en est c'est fait
de nombreuses victimes
les résistance islamique les voici
formidablement vulnérables et pourtant
pour tenter de venir à bout de cette
guérilla l'armée soviétique et fait
passer soixante dix mille hommes en
afghanistan
soixante dix mille hommes armés
jusqu'aux dents avec des blindés des
avions des hélicoptères en face d'eux
des maquisards équipés de bric et de
broc des guerriers qui achètent leurs
armes ou plutôt des copies d'armes au
pakistan dans des villages comme celui
ci dahra le village où l'on recharge une
à une les douilles de cartouche
ramassées après chaque accrochage
c'est dérisoire malgré tout les
soviétiques sont contraints d'utiliser
les grands moyens pour contenir ce
mouvement de résistance qui voit ses
rangs grossir de semaine en semaine
bombardements destruction de villages
contrôlée par les rebelles
dans certaines régions ce qui fut
l'afghanistan la firme les hélicoptères
attacked au napalm les zones non
habitées
celle où les mecs qui se regroupent
après leur coup de main enfin l'exode
des centaines de milliers de réfugiés et
c'est de retrouver côté pakistanais
ce qu'ils ont perdu côté afghan une
chance de survivre
ce sont ces hommes et ces femmes qui
portent aujourd'hui les accusations les
plus graves contre l'armée soviétique
ils l'accusent d'utiliser des gaz de
combat lors d'attaqués contre les
localités soupçonnés d'héberger les
résistance islamique mille personnes
auraient trouvé la mort lors de ces
actions récentes qui ont porté un rude
coup aux combattants musulmans et
terriblement à cannes un l'actualité
média tu sais qu'on oublie très vite et
qu'on s'habitue qu'il ya une
banalisation
oui par exemple au 19e siècle un chahut
ce 19ème siècle était dominée par le
drame de la grèce par exemple eh bien il
ya eu plusieurs générations d'européens
qui ont vécu dans la fascination du
drame du martyr que vivait la grèce sous
le joug turc de cet enfant grave c'est
qu'ils demandaient de la poudre et des
balles une génération de byron à victor
hugo en passant par delacroix
alors qu'aujourd'hui que se passe-t-il
il y à un moment d'émotion hier le chili
le chili tout le monde avait un peu de
chimie au coeur c'était le symbole de ce
qu'on avait refusé de la victoire
absolument inacceptable de la force
aveugle et puis un peu le chili est
devenue un pays là bas lointain en
amérique latine là où il ya tellement de
coups d'état militaires et l'afghanistan
l'afghanistan quand les soviétiques sont
rentrés d'afghanistan il ya une émotion
profonde un choc que tout le monde a
ressenti je dis à tout le monde même
ceux qui l'ont approuvé
or c'est aujourd'hui que le pire se
déroule c'est aujourd'hui qu'un petit
peuple à kaboul temps de se soulever
comme l'avait fait le petit peuple de
téhéran contre une autre des dictatures
et qui l'écrasé qu'il est subjuguée par
une force supérieure
c'est aujourd'hui que des résistants
mallarmé mal entraînés abandonnés par
ceux là même qui les ont encouragés à se
révolter
il faut le dire sont broyés
implacablement par une force mécanique
moderne supérieur et entraînent dans
leurs débats que les femmes des enfants
qui vont submergé les camps de réfugiés
or l'afghanistan est en train de revenir
un petit pays là bas entre la chine et
le pakistan et ses larmes principal des
oppresseurs que le fait qu'aujourd'hui
on s'habitue à tout mais minime alaigne
acceptable alors qu'au contraire la
seule arme qu'on pourrait leur poser
ça serait le refus absolu de l'oubli la
fin des voyages de valéry giscard
d'estaing dans les émirats le chef de
l'état en effet quitter tout à l'heure à
bout débit pour se rendre en jordanie
georges bortoli fait maintenant pour
nous le bilan de ces quatre étapes dans
les émirats
pendant que le président giscard
d'estaing est en train de prendre congé
dans une ambiance particulièrement
chaleureuse
des français des émirats arabes unis on
peut faire un rapide bilan de ces six
jours du président français sur les
bords du golfe persique
premièrement un développement politique
important avec l'apparition du mode auto
détermination s'appliquant aux
palestiniens des territoires occupés
il faut noter que cette position
française doit maintenant se rallier à
elle l'un après l'autre les pays de la
communauté européenne
deuxièmement berardi le développement
économique
les contrats signés ou en cours de
préparation par les ministres qui
accompagnent le président de la
république vont de la coopération
agricole à l'énergie solaire en passant
bien entendu par un développement des
livraisons de pétrole notamment dans
l'émirat du qatar mais assez contrat
précis ponctuelle il faut ajouter que
nous avons assisté ici à abou dhabi à
une percée de l'idée de trilogue faire
coopérer de façon durable
l'europe lés pays arabe et l'afrique
c'est-à-dire trois ans semblant
l'habitude d'investir ensemble de faire
des grands projets ensemble et je posais
ajouté ans en outre que cette
coopération économique devrait dans
l'idée du président de la république
prendre une dimension supplémentaire qui
serait un aspect politique et à ce
propos le chef de l'état c'est tout à
l'heure une confidence sur penny guillon
française un an ni parlant précisément
de l'approvisionnement pétrolier de la
france vous invite l écouter ce que je
peux vous dire ce que la politique de la
france est apprécié que le rôle de la
france est apprécié et que mes
interlocuteurs ont témoigné d'un très
grand souci de voir la france est
épargnée par les risques ou par les
incertitudes qui peuvent affecter son
approvisionnement
valéry giscard d'estaing qui est donc
depuis ce soit en jordanie il doit y
rencontrer bien sûr le roi hussein noël
copains a demandé au souverain jordanien
sa conception de l'autodétermination des
palestiniens quand
je ne peux pas je n'ai jamais pu
accepter que moi on importe quel autre
personnalité responsable du monde arabe
ou du monde entier puissent décider pour
les palestiniens de leur avenir
mais quand ils auront recouvré leur
territoire j'ai toujours eu une fois
immense dans le fait que le choix du
plus grand nombre sera quelque chose que
nous assimilons douce et que tout le
monde pourra admettre
de toute façon ce n'est pas un secret
que c'est l'auto détermination que nous
recherchons pour et je suis persuadé que
ce choix une fois reconnues sera
acceptée par nous tous
après la jordanie il y aura encore une
étape en arabie saoudite et le président
français ne regagnera paris qu'en début
de semaine prochaine au terme de son
plus long voyage à l'étranger
salvador situation toujours aussi
dramatique
nombreux sont les dirigeants d'amérique
centrale à craindre une intervention
américaine
voici ce soir des images
impressionnantes on y ramasse en effet
vous voyez les cadavres comme les
poubelles au coin des rues
ces images parlent d'elles mêmes nous
avons expurgée de leurs séquences et fut
brutal
france une délégation du crif le conseil
représentatif des institutions juives en
france en fin d'après midi à l'hôtel
matignon
le crif 7 est ému des prises de position
française précisément sur le problème
des palestiniens
une initiative du secrétaire général du
parti républicain qui veut proposer à
georges marchais de rencontrer
l'ambassadeur soviétique à paris afin
d'obtenir la sortie du ray cesse de la
mère et de la soeur de gianni de qt un
attentat en guadeloupe
raymond viviès conseiller général de
pointe à pitre
ardent défenseur de l'as des panthères
de motivation a été grièvement blessé ce
matin d'une balle dans la tête
et puis le procès des manifestants de
plogoff s'est passé cet après midi à
quimper et claude sérillon était notre
envoyé spécial sur place de l'ange oui
c'était plogoff à quimper à 45 km de
distance des hommes et des femmes du cap
sizun sont venus chanter en breton des
cantiques de résistance de résistance à
une menace nucléaire mais de résistance
aussi à une occupation fronde autour du
cou valise à la main il voulait ce matin
rejoindre en prison les neuf inculpés en
vertu de la loi anti casseurs cet après
midi dans la grande salle de ce palais
de justice de quimper
les accusés pris par les gendarmes dans
un champ vendredi 29 février vers 17h
ressembler aux pays qu'ils défendent
peu bavard tranchant comme cet homme de
55 ans ted carval grand bonhomme carrés
qui laisse pendre ses mains de chaque
côté de son corps des mains faites par
le travail dans la marine
quant aux faits aux faits seuls qui sont
nécessairement étudiée par le tribunal
dans le cadre de la procédure de
flagrant délit
il reste bien contradictoires l'un at il
tiré avec sa fronde pourquoi l'autre
porte est il un morceau dardoise gros
comme une petite main enfants quelle
injure à proférer ce dernier à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre à tous
ceux ci les gendarmes répondre avec
méticulosité horaires termes
stratégiques ressemblant à une partie
d'échecs
le président du tribunal montrera il est
vrai beaucoup d'attention aux
différentes déclarations on a peu parlé
du nucléaire on a simplement témoigner
d'un climat sain climat ou les lances
pierres se bat contre un futur qui les
inquiète
dérisoire débat où les gendarmes
reconnaissent les agresseurs à leurs
habits de marins habite
demain à toute une population qui a
commencé soulignera un avocat de la
défense qui a la responsabilité des
actes de violence provocation ou
répression force doit rester à la loi
dit on il n'est pas certain qu'à nouveau
la procédure trop rapide trop imprécises
des flagrants délits soit la mieux
adaptée pour forcer la vie d'homme et de
femme résolument j'allais dire
viscéralement opposé non seulement une
construction de centrales nucléaires
mais également la présence permanente de
forces de police ajoute que le procès se
poursuit et se terminera je pense tard
dans la nuit
et puis le priant les radicaux de gauche
michel crêpes whaou va demander au
président république l'abandon du projet
de centrale de plogoff la démission de
monseigneur l'allier archevêque de
besançon pour raisons de santé
monseigneur l'allier à 73 après la
diffusion de notre reportage sur les
conditions scandaleuses dans lesquelles
voyagent les chevaux destinés à la
boucherie réactions ont été vives et
vous avez été très nombreux à nous
téléphoner pour vous dire pour nous dire
votre indignation c'est pourquoi nous
avons décidé de ne pas nous en tenir là
et je vous propose d'aller plus loin
avec pyatt bresse et patrice pollet qui
reviennent sur ce dossier un volcan vers
midi deux kilomètres on a beaucoup
10 à 12 sous le par à gorée
pendant ce long voyage vers les
abattoirs français certains chevaux
s'étrangle d'autres se blesse qu'en se
battant une heure de maladie s'il ya des
chevaux qui sont stationnés un
changement va débarquer les choses qui
sont à l'intérieur et aurait besoin de
voir et de manger ça dépend de vous ça
aussi il faut continuellement pour aller
décharger les chevaux qui étaient là bas
et on peut les a broyés parfaitement
dans le camion et leur donner à manger
se soigner pas de nourriture
moi je suis ici simplement à fonctionner
non pas d'un fonctionnaire et un
vacataire qui vient faire du travail
1h ou 2h ou 3h par jour au maximum je
n'ai aucun pouvoir je n'ai même pas un
bureau qu'est-ce que vous décidez alors
s'ils sont pas bons je n'ai même pas le
rendu est refoulé vous laissez passer
s'ils sont pas remplies je ne peux pas
affolé il ya des accords avec les pays
bas
alors à quoi ça sert comme une soyez ici
pour les surveiller il faut demander ça
vous aurez culture par train camion
bateau
la france importe chaque année 350 mille
chevaux de boucherie
car l'élevage français est insuffisant
pourtant les paysans n'hésite pas à se
séparer de leurs chevaux lorsqu'ils ne
sont plus utiles fait longtemps que vous
avez ces chevaux là oui ça fait enfin la
giz elle a 10 ans enfin j'en avais
toujours depuis débris qui je fais le
métier c'est un peu contradictoire le
fait d'aimer travailler avec les cdd
mais la présence des chevaux et de les
élever pour les envoyer sous moi c'est
plus le moment de travailler tout avec
des fous parce que ça n'avance pas assez
vite
mais si on écrit l'élevage c'est quelque
chose c'est pour profiter de la vente
une fois
quand on voit que comme on n'a plus
besoin que ces vieux camp peut plus
travailler avec c'est le moment de les
liquider ses blessures ses morsures ses
marques au fer rouge
c'était panique dans les yeux pourraient
être évités c'est un long calvaire
inutile pour des chevaux qui vont mourir
bien sûr c'est une affaire qui a indigné
brigitte bardot lorsqu'elle a découvert
ces images dans notre journal hier à 20h
patricia charnolé et patrice du ter
viennent de la rencontrer
la face et duchesses c'est une jument
que je vienne sauvés des abattoirs
elle aurait dû maintenant elle devrait
être morte elle est merveilleuse et à la
vie jours de vie commune avec moi et je
laisse justement pour parler de ce genre
de choses avec les gens sachent qu'un
cheval c'est un peu comme un chien comme
ami de l'homme ça répond à son nom c'est
merveilleux ça aide toute ta vie c'est
formidable alors quand j'ai vu que j'ai
vu hier j'ai pleuré j'ai pleuré j'ai pas
honte de le dire parce que ce que j'ai
vu absolument abominable qu'on mange des
chevaux bon je trouve que déjà cette
horrible
la france est un est le deuxième pays au
monde qui mangent des chevaux avant
galite ali mais il ya des tas de pays
qui ne mangent pas de chevaux qui se
portent pas plus mal pour ça tout ça
dégueulasse et plus la façon dont on les
transporte que ce soit par bateau ou par
train les chevaux sont blessés ils ont
les pattes cassées
ils sont blessés de toute façon ils
arrivent dans les conditions abominables
il faut quelquefois 7000 km dans un
train et quand ils sont dans les bateaux
et qui sont cassés les pattes parce
qu'elle est du tangage du roulier de
spera on les chèques par dessus bord
vivent un les pattes cassées beau c'est
monstrueux quand est ce que ce n'est pas
un peu utopique de demander aux gens
d'arrêter de manger du cheval comment
faire alors bon quand on se bat pour des
causes comme les bébés phoques par
exemple on est obligé d'être de demander
un gouvernement de faire une loi
d'interdire quelque chose et c'est le
fait de ne plus manger de viande de
cheval
les français peuvent faire leur choix
tout seul ils n'ont qu'à plus manger de
viande de cheval et puis c'est tout bon
quand nous mangeons plus de l'homme de
cheval s'en porteront pas plus mal et on
ne fera plus subir aux chevaux qui sont
des animaux fantastiques qui sont
proches de l'homme qu'ils l'aident le
serbe toute la clique leur vie bon on
n'a pas le droit devant pour qu'on mange
pas de chien ou du chat
1° français pensent qu'à bouffer ils
sont gros et gras il meurt d'un
infarctus et les femmes font des régimes
qui mangent moins qu'il commence par
arrêter le cheval c'est dégoûtant chaud
c'est ignoble ça devrait être interdit
de manger du cheval
eh bien avec brigitte bardot précisément
notre émission du 15 mars samedi et demi
sera entièrement consacré à ce problème
et la semaine suivante le 23 les
missions de louis rolland neil les
animaux et des hommes expliquera comment
on peut sauver de la boucherie et
chevaux qui ne sont plus bons pour le
service
pas de libération des prix des
médicaments contrairement à ce
qu'espéraient les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques mais une politique
nouvelle s'amorce pour que la france
puisse se maintenir à la quatrième place
sur le marché mondial sans pour autant
accentue les difficultés des caisses
d'assurance maladie c'est ce qu'a laissé
entendre jacques barrot le ministre de
la santé que nous entendrons dans le
journal de 12h15 à 18 ans de réclusion
requis par l'avocat général contre les
deux meurtriers du représentant de l'olp
et à paris et des dinka lac
verdict demain et puis vous souvenez
sans doute du drame de vitry un jeune
algérien avait été tué par un gardien
d'immeuble nous connaissons mal les
conditions de vie de ces jeunes immigrés
que l'on a trop tendance à assimiler
avec des loubards et bien nous sommes ce
soir en possession d'un document filmé
par le groupe auquel appartenait ce
jeune abdelkader un film dont le
tournage a duré un an
vous verrez ce document demain notre
émission d'antenne 2010 un document qui
sera suivie d'un débat
d'ores et déjà nous en propose un
extrait il vous permettra de mieux
comprendre
je vous rappelle que ce sont des jeunes
immigrés qui tenait eux mêmes la caméra
moi je double catastrophique si je sors
pas de second choix judor jeu
je veux dans d'enfer net temps les mal
placé on est les jeunes et sont mal
passées dans un milieu social
samedi comme ça en plus ça dépend de
quel jeune 6 a un fils à papa
puis il a toutes les portes sont
ouvertes a ni études payées et tout
tranquille je tous là d'études par
contre à son père si les ouvriers
s'il veut s'amuser comme le fils à papa
sinon il se prive de tout un pays les
sept se dégager de ses copains tout ça
du mauvaises fréquentations et c'est à
moi je crois que c'est pas normal
pourquoi on devrait avoir les mêmes
chances à cause du gouvernement s'est il
disait à un gouvernement démocratique
c'est pour ça gouvernements capitalistes
c'est pourri dans leur marque comme
liste c'est la même chose même si un
gouvernement comme lui ça changera façon
tout ça c'est de la démagogie c'est
officiel ouais
puisque vous lie la socialiste ça si il
faut des gars rentrent mais ils s'en
foutent mitterrand en marché ils sont
assis sur une chaise dollars faillite où
ils en ont rien à [ __ ] que la gauche a
pas sous cape face moi mais ils sont
payés ils ont la raconte et où il joue
en retraite assurée ça fait ça à faire
au moins 21 ans mon père qui les a tous
l'âge de ma soeur
22e sur sa femme bhutto donc ce demain
ce document tourné par des jeunes
immigrés dans antenne du midi sports
maintenant il y avait aujourd'hui deux
demi étapes de paris nice matin l'équipe
du norvégien clud sénat remporté la
course contre la montre par équipes
entre barbizon énamouré cet après midi
c'est le néerlandais jan race qui a
remporté au sprint la course en ligne
nemours auxerre lucent conserve le
maillot blanc du leader le suédois prime
est à 9 secondes et le néerlandais
knetemann à 12 secondes
bernard hinault qui a perdu ce matin 3
minutes 46 contre la montre est assez
loin au classement général
l'arrivée d'un bébé viendra
y'avait pas car c'est aujourd'hui à
vincennes dans le prix
d'anjou pour gagner il fallait jouer las
le 9 ou le cette combinaison qui vous
rapportent dans l'ordre 4140 de francs
dans un ordre différent 5 175 francs
donc tout cela pour 5 francs
mais comme vous le voyez le 15 n'est pas
parti donc les parieurs qui ont joué le
là si vous voulez le 9 et le 15 gagnent
tout de même le couple et c'est à dire
280 750 pour 5 francs hier soir dans ses
pronostics piel bresse vous avez donné
ces trois jours la météo aujourd'hui la
plus sûre tout le nord de la loire mais
il a fait beau sur la moitié sud est du
pays le quart sud-est devrais je dire du
pays alors laurent broomhead la même
chose pour demain après demain et
dimanche
mais du mauvais temps une zone de plus
en train de traverser le pays d'ouest en
est cette nuit encore des pluies dans
l'ès demain beaucoup beaucoup de nuages
avec de la pluie de l'alsace la lorraine
jusqu'au jura la région méditerranéenne
et même les pyrénées orientales avec de
la neige au-dessus d'environ quinze 100
m se rase et du pis ça va un peu
s'améliorer un temps comme on dit un
stade c'est à dire alternance de
passages nuageux et de quelques
éclaircies mais encore des averses et
des giboulées puis surtout du vent de
nord-ouest qui va venir très fort en
revanche sur les côtes de l'atlantique
et mistral et tramontane en méditerranée
ça c'est pour vendredi samedi le temps
va s'améliorer encore des nuages encore
des averses principalement dans l'est
encore des giboulées
mais les éclaircies devenu un peu plus
belles et des températures fraîches et
puis malheureusement samedi soir une
nouvelle zone depuis lui arrive devrait
arriver sur l'ouest du pays
ce qui signifie c'est pas compliqué
deviner que c'est plus vont traverser le
pays dimanche à dimanche avec des
parapluies des bottes et les
imperméables à langon et puis ce soir
nous sommes heureux de vous annoncer la
naissance d'un nouveau confrère un
hebdomadaire communiste qui a pris pour
devise nous vivons le temps des
révolutions son titre d'ailleurs
révolution guy hermier y signe
l'éditorial le veut différente ses
confrères à tous points de vue voilà ce
soir et avec l'hôte vous présentera le
dernier journal aux environs de minuit
et puis à 12h45 vous avez rendez vous
demain avec patrick l'europe vous
souhaite une très très bonne soirée
j'espère vous retrouver demain à 20
heures